hello there reject nation
I am discount markiplier and I'm
discount that one guy from blind wave
we're gonna do a top reward tier video
request TJ has requested a heist with
markiplier I saw the teaser for this a
long time ago I barely remember it it's
a choose-your-own-adventure kind of game
it's like Bandersnatch this is gonna be
very disturbing I'm excited and we've
never done something like this before a
reaction to fortune isn't sure and I've
never even played a game like this oh
the Goosebumps book that was good we
were in third grade
and then mrs. Renteria would be like and
then he stuck his hand in the glass and
then and then we'd always at least one
more page
[Music]
Valley Performing Arts Center
maybe wow this is how markiplier sees
things
hardcore markiplier
edge text
[Music]
why are you really doing this no don't
this whole thing himself
Forbes is Frank Martin pliers mama top
earning youtubers millions of dollars
worth I can't even consider myself
discount employer three three you'll be
just fine but if you deviate from it for
even a single moment you okay whoa damn
markiplier
this is so cool he looks really at home
in this high sting game is that meat
where's my VR goggles what do you think
you're doing Oh No the old state trick
I'm not falling for that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
the exact information needed two of us
we can do this I love guarding a big
safe this wasn't in the plans there are
two keys for this vault we need to get
them from those guards or any guards
that are you mean less competent than
those why don't you go back the way we
came go up why not be back in a flash
buddy doggy look out for the big wolf
I think we need we're doing really well
so far let's choose your own adventure
you ready
[Music]
working towards all those years it's
finally ours this is gonna change our
lives forever it's fine
this is see two ways out of here it just
so happens to be a sewer that runs deep
Oh John which one oh man do you want to
go you want got a sneaky like something
smarter do we want to be smart we don't
we have to choose fast I wish you I'm
with guns please I'm sorry
I want to win this I want to see the
complicated next time we're going to
complicated oh no oh no we're not
disgusting yeah yeah well they're like
Google Marcus
hide putting a sewer entrance underneath
what was supposed to be the most secure
vault in the museum
it's just grossly irresponsible you know
[Music]
is like an internet escape route I know
you know you're right say this much I
really want markiplier to bring this
character to the big screen Dino
big screen choose your own heist
Tom Cruise will make it happen
hurry man
slow down man all right let's keep
moving
[Music]
I'm sorry but it was sorry's dark it's
dirty
damn we can go back and choose oh I'm
sorry guys looks like I might be
changing I think what's off two
different ways down there
nice or it didn't sound that close so
this is keep moving in front of us the
dark tunnel they have that security
guard just ran down from and then
screamed and then died in or in the
light tunnel where there's possibly a
end to it where it might drain to an
escape so we can be scot-free away our
balloons which is gonna be
well obviously the dark tunnel all right
geez yeah his hair is not consistent
with the last take oh I think issues
markiplier we could split up
yeah that's great we should split up
cover more ground I'll keep moving
forward and you go back the way we came
and if either my name's it we'll just uh
scream the end screens are confusing
because they make me think I kind of
choose right over oh no dad kill
markiplier no markiplier and you gave me
crap for going into the sewer oh [ __ ]
this we're gonna do this we're gonna is
you you gave me crap for not making fun
decisions I want you to remember this
alright so all sneaky-like this is
retrace our steps here scot-free
gonna be said dark tunnel right yeah it
was a dark tunnel all right split up oh
okay alright well then let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh look at this you see what I see
yeah I see an exit okay I see I see two
exits which which means that we really
gotta split up now ten minutes
everything Dory John juice I'll go down
this way guess we should it seems like
it's not splitting up has more content
but let's see he seems like he wants us
to split up so let's do it before we
split up maybe you could just um like
keep looking at me for just a little bit
longer
you know just too much
[Music]
you got Jack blacked all right we're
going back one won't you obviously don't
we're gonna we're gonna nuts we're gonna
YouTube wants you to u2 wants to have
the wash time that's right
longer clubs for clutter the eaves we're
getting out of here close my contacts
are drying out
was that you
do you touching yourself feeling lost
we are evil we will kill you mr. bit to
seem like you really meant that
yes karate-chopping
[Music]
[Music]
that you see on the next corner crew
there was no rape oh wow that we okay so
judging by the decor I'm guessing that
this is the nice so let's try to get
through as quickly as possible and
actually I'm thinking this might be the
way out oh and then one person for
tunnel will collapse if two people go
down the single tunnel
[Music]
[Laughter]
to see if anybody's following us it'll
be perfect so let's split up is four
minutes in London it's the rules and I
follow the rules except when we brought
museums and we kind of break the rules
but we make our own rules okay it's okay
just one is everything all right if
we're going by time theory I think that
was the wrong choice which means that
we're gonna be back up here in exactly
five minutes no matter what happens so
you go down that tunnel I'll go down
this tunnel and if you see
ah [ __ ] I don't want to do this without
markiplier here I know
you tired
SEC Ken Marino from Party Down
now sit
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what he started from the beginning
damned
31 so did we beat it I don't know I
think we just do we just keep playing
maybe I don't know I don't know what
we're supposed to do now know if there's
a way to win
or if we just keep on going
everybody's relying on game theory oh
come on people that's what these things
are for you gotta tear them apart your
cell we got to do make this a whole
series words every time here for two
hours every two hours or ten hours
let me just see one thing one thing I
know we won because we were back to the
beginning yeah I mean we didn't wait we
just made it to the ending so the whole
point is to try to find the codes yeah
whoa
[Music]
it sure does I think this time maybe we
actually have to split up I know this is
gonna survive I need the right call die
oh you didn't know millions of YouTube
fans will be due to die I'm sure she'll
be confused but if you just tell her I
got saving you know I don't know gonna
live from the sea retreat I hit the pole
yeah
now just listen
by mark yeah
[Music]
and we ain't getting out of this
[Music]
sacrifice meant nothing interesting and
how many alternate endings okay maybe
it's not the kind of game you win so
much as experience through multiple
perspectives
[Music]
okay yeah we got the 31 a 31 before eyes
had to confirm then yeah all right
well dude that's a leaker like I was
just in such admiration of it from
beginning to end sometimes we get these
requests you know like at the top reward
tier requests where you don't know we're
walking into so there's some times
especially where like we could be here
for a long time and we don't know if
it's something that we're gonna
ultimately enjoy so there could be
hesitation and I'll admit that was
definitely a feeling I was happening
with this was like really I don't know
about this end up watching it clicked
from beginning to end I was so enamored
by the whole thing I loved it
markiplier his personality for this and
showing off some of his like comedic
acting skills I think is great like this
character alone I'm like I wanted to see
a movie of this character yeah I just
wanna keep following a morality I really
want to go back and just keep doing the
different alternative I would be fun to
keep playing the game of course but just
seeing like a character are you money in
the middle I want to see this character
brought to the big screen in some way
just this like cartoonish whimsical bank
robber or thief you know like that seems
like such a great character and he's so
good at it he's got this right level of
surrealism and I love the physical gags
the bit was a big part of the joke is
it's obviously not him doing the stunts
and they even like double down on the
joke of doll that balls of the drags ya
know it's got the perfect employer
self-aware self-deprecating humor and
also I mean like yeah then one of the
biggest impacts of this was market
players markup Liars ability as a
performer gets playa I know it's a
player today Marco pliers ability as a
performer not only as a community
performer but also like in the surreal
ending bit I was pretty involved by that
too and I like that this also committed
to being kind of
weird and creepy as well as funny and
amusing you know like the cults that
like when they're following you down the
hall the perspective shooting style
really does make things a little bit
intense at least well it starts off as
kind of a whimsical almost like a Disney
appropriate heist movie it's like this
family-friendly kind of like a cartoony
sort of heist thing right and that was
that was really engrossing it was still
having a really good time and then I did
appreciate how get down under and you're
trying to escape how it shifts it's it
like this horror movie and he really
commits by the time you get to at least
one of these ending moments I don't know
if that's how all of them ultimately
gets you by 31 - 31
I thought the effects on there were
great and I gotta say like for this
transition of what he's done with his
career is so impressive so much of us
know markiplier for being like one of
the ultimate ragers one of the ultimate
let's players
vibe that's a pretty boy hey I do love
watching those videos I really got into
markiplier from just watching more of
his personality driven interviews some
of his more thoughtful provoking sort of
meditative videos or just watching
interviews of him this is like such a
great transition like this is a great
way to keep YouTube alive I think for
doing something yeah of the gamer making
a interactive game through the YouTube
video format by taking advantage of the
choice of end screens and I know he's
not the firt like remember Jeremy John's
did something like this maybe they're
not the only ones when Jeremy Johnson
liked this for his solo a Star Wars
story review where you can like choose
which opinion and I thought really cool
doing this were the level of production
quality you know of making an immersive
game experience from the gamer I think
is such a wonderful transition combining
both his gaming energy enthusiasm
sensibility along with hilarious
personality and comedic timing that he
has just makes for a great video this is
this was really impressive really
impressive and then it takes what's
already appealing about him because he's
still walking through a game with you
Zach and he's still reacting to things
and you're still bringing as
personalities this is a yeah really nice
synthesis of where you came from and
where you're going like this is a good
transition yeah love it I think a lot of
people try to leap from one thing to
another and this is
like I'm creative I'm excited to see
where he took they took a long time put
it together and then after watching just
what they had to shoes can't imagine
like how long this really did take to
assemble how much planning went into
making this worse but the reshoot system
is - yeah yeah like an acute seeing it
and like seeing how well it flows as a
game and then choosing which ending and
I thought - in terms of like scene work
it's so much of his you know YouTube
personalities work involves interacting
with the camera and really some making
you feel like you're in a room with him
like he's talking to you one-on-one that
was a great way for him to prove like
he's he's like the perfect fit for this
I don't know what his overall Mamun what
is this I don't know if he came up with
this I don't know if someone approached
him with this idea I don't know it's
kind of magical to me and inspiring yeah
this is great
Thank You TJ for requesting this I
really love this I really thought this
was great this is good this is this is
great more of these please yeah guys you
can subscribe to if you haven't done so
already it's the most popular youtubers
ever hurts the markiplier language you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell TJ I'm glad
that you had a good Halloween with your
daughter the whole family got dressed up
their baby girls sky and his hot wife
Teej of course so TJ was dressed up as a
priest his wife was dressed up as a nun
Skye was dressed up as a stripper
two-year-old strippers totally oh yeah
and then that's walked around throwing
holy water on their little girl and
every time she said trick-or-treat they
said that that is a sin yeah then he
would have to take her to a confessional
booth and make her confess for
participating in the satanic holiday you
got to instill the Catholic guilt as
early as possible and the best way to do
it is on Halloween this one is most
effective yes is when you seep it in
before all the other core thoughts and
ideas explore exactly where it's too
late no matter what how much little be
anything for the rest unless you suffer
you did good nice with TJ turning tricks
and that were you good actually really
great like trick-or-treating
it would be mad at houses you go do it
want to go in this house yes
trick-or-treat you sawed-off for that
which one do you want and if you choose
trick it's as always prostitution thanks
for getting my family friendly